ici ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
gérard darmon j'aimerais que quelqu'un
rappelle ce qu'est le ccf pour nos
téléspectateurs qui veulent faire eric
basset de mon point de vue c'est un
collectif qui essayent de transformer
les français musulmans en musulmans
français c'est-à-dire d'appuyer tant
qu'ils peuvent sur la touche
communautaire de séparer pour mieux la
manipuler pour mieux la contrôler la
communauté musulmane de la communauté
nationale
d'ailleurs on l'a vu dans les marches
contre l'islamophobie ou n'est pas
question de l'islamophobie l'exaltation
de quelque chose qui qui ressemble
beaucoup à une forme de crypto islamisme
on aimerait beaucoup que vous dénonciez
aussi les crimes de l'islam politique
mais vous ne le faites pas parce que
vous êtes le visage découvert si j'ose
dire le visage dévoilé le visage féminin
le visage souriant de l'islamisme donc
voilà vous êtes la presse et la phase
aller je vais pas vous laisser tous
m'attaque et on ne voudrait pas rouge à
lèvres mais attendez allez-y files
abonnement je me suis interrogé sur la
question puisque monsieur mahjoubi est
en train d'évoquer la question de zineb
el rhazoui alors ça je voudrais
l'évacuer tout de suite la liberté
d'expression que vous défendez tous bec
et ongles pour dîner rasoul y compris
quand elle appelle à tirer à balles
réelles sur les quartiers populaires
elle doit pouvoir être aussi ma liberté
d'expression d'accord pizza sur la note
s'il vous plaît vous a laissé parler
vous allez me laisser terminer parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas ma fait je pas
venu ici pour me faire lyncher par un
deux trois quatre d'accord je voudrais
juste amour des champions c'est pas le
lynchage
je voudrais juste terminer mon propos
vous mais j'ai terminé mon propos s'il
vous plaît nationale en lui est ce que
vous vivez avec des gardes du corps joue
pas pardon est-ce que c'est geoffrey
lejeune qui vont demander si avec des
gardes du corps en rapport à ciney ben
parce que l ouïe non mais c'est pas du
tout la contrainte pour pouvoir être
aujourd'hui bénéficier d'une liberté
d'expression est ce qu'il faut attendre
qu'on soit menacé ma liberté
d'expression une insidieuse que ça sert
à se défendre mais pas me louper je
voudrais juste pouvoir finir parce que
je suis pas venu ici sinon vers les îles
j'ai envie de tuer sénégalais dessous je
prends ma mais appelle moi je colle pas
rien
allez passer un sale quart d'heure où je
suis venu parce que je suis courageuse
monsieur parce que quand on m'appelle on
invite après c'est pas la charge en
hauteur du courage incroyable et c'est
la réponse est fou c'est dingue
en fait vous sentez puissant parce que
vous êtes plusieurs c'est pas parce que
vous êtes plusieurs que vous avez raison
monsieur votre arrivée vous a coupé ses
fous en fait allez messieurs mahjoubi
même actif sur la question des
inégalités
cinebel rhazoui j'ai le droit de la
critiquer dans la mesure où elle a fait
des tweets me désignant mois comme
nazislamiste hashtag nazislamiste à
partir de là j'ai saisi la justice
j'attends que la justice par son travail
maintenant j'ai le droit aussi de
désigner zineb el rhazoui comme incitant
à la haine
j'ai le droit puisqu'elle est libre de
s'exprimer et elle a le droit de dire ce
qu'elle dit j'ai aussi le droit du roi
la nation dans l'axé enfants et son mari
jsk est ce que moi attendent après ça
aussi il faut que vraiment il faut
remettre les choses à leur place
est-ce que là vous avez en face de vous
faire et abonnements m il faut que vous
sortiez de 7,7
ce mécanisme systématique qui consiste
lorsqu'un musulman ou un militant
identifié comme étant musulman c'est
quelque chose dit quelque chose vous
convoquer une espèce de de
responsabilité collective maison fatiha
fatiha
je ne suis pas venu ici aujourd'hui pour
m'expliquer sur les expliquer les propos
de pierre paul jacques ou 2 6 me de ca
vous madame ne suis pas venu et
aujourd'hui pour expliquer la question
parce que je vois très bien qui vous
faites allusion aujourd'hui vous parler
de ce récit à mehdi qui a eu un un
désaccord avec 10 nouvelles races mais
sur internet
désolé ne suis pas venu aujourd'hui oui
il a posé des questions il a fait ce
qu'il a voulu
je ne comprendrais pas la raison pour
laquelle non seulement les autres
courent et moi et la justice passera à
monsieur justice me dire ah ça je sers
bien où elle habite et le condamne
données de l'islam qui est quand même à
la base faut le dire moi j'ai appris
l'arabe est une religion magnifique
poétique et c'est vrai que ce qui est de
ski et riespach dont mademoiselle vous
interrompre ça n'a rien à voir avec vous
je n'ai pas pu me retenir cyril il me
faisait du bien mais ce qui me fait ce
qu'il m'a abîmé un peu psychologiquement
c'est que à la base mais cela met quand
même une religion etc sens
mais en tant que tel et c'est vrai
qu'entendre toute la journée ce mot qui
revient à cause de ces terroristes qui
quand même atrophie quelque chose qui à
la base de demander qu'à être une
religion comme les autres est quelque
chose qui même chez un athée comme moi
et je suis athée comme un singe est
quelque chose qui donne une sorte de
nausée je voulais je trouve cette
parenthèse mais tu te reconnais que ils
savent toi quelqu'un être cultivée qui
va vers le savoir
2 tu viens de le dire de questions il ya
des poètes il ya des wii et philosophe
ccf pardon je n'ai rien à voir avec
l'islam et où la voir avec l'islamisme
juste le débat complètement différent
sur le propos que vous venez de tenir
monsieur naulleau vous accusez le ccf
l'islam politique
je vais répondre à votre question mais
je voudrais d'abord préciser une chose
je ne suis pas je n'ai pas de fonction
officielle au ccf je ne suis pas salarié
de bénévolat est aussi bénévole vitesse
et pourrairent dogan on le sait est
écoutée quand vous vous pavaner en
couverture et pour les magazines détenus
par un marchand d'armes
c'est pour donner un mineur de 15 ans je
suis plus fier d'être son hamburger au
magazine et lumière défendre et remis
aux gammes armada maintenant je voudrais
terminer bédié l'a pas fini une phrase
c'est vrai sur le tribunal mais je me
coupais depuis tout à l'heure
s'il vous plaît faïza ben moi m moi la
question qu'un sur escaut un spectacle
synology de la question qui intéresse
les téléspectateurs
c est ce que vous pensez que le ministre
de l'intérieur qui veut dissoudre le ccf
se trompe ben c'est bien sûr que oui et
mais pourquoi pourquoi il veut vous
dissoudre moi je pense que déjà cette
proposition elle est complètement à côté
de la plaque pour quelle raison en fait
il faut il faut refaire un petit peu
peut-être pour le téléspectateur la
genèse de l'histoire pourquoi est-ce que
le ccf s'est retrouvé dans cette
histoire mais le père de famille qui est
à l'origine de la vidéo dans laquelle il
a désigné samuel pâti comme étant un
professeur qui a montré des caricatures
à ses élèves
ce parent d'élève a fait une vidéo il
diffuse la vidéo je crois que c'était le
7 octobre le 10 octobre
ce parent d'élève contact cci à 7 1
samedi et donc ils tombent le protocole
au ccf vous
avait un standard vous appelez le
standard quand vous voulez signalé en
fait donc vous prêt que vous vous pensez
avoir été victime un fait à caractère
islamophobe vous appelez la standardiste
la standardiste tran votre votre
déposition prend votre témoignage
elle note tout et elle vous informe que
dans le votre dossier va être transmis
un juriste et que le juriste
s'il juge que vous êtes effectivement
victime d'un d'une discrimination
islamophobe va vous rappeler donc le 12
le disent c'est monsieur appelle donc
c'est un samedi le 12 le ccf enregistre
sa demande donc le lundi au dos de
retour au bureau le lundi
là la dame qui s'entretient avec le père
de famille qui aujourd'hui mises en
cause dans cette vidéo elle lui elle lui
ordonne de supprimer cette vidéo
pourquoi parce que le ccf ne peut pas
travailler sereinement avec une hystérie
sur les réseaux sociaux
le seuil est venu à demander à ce
monsieur expressément de supprimer la
vidéo parce que premièrement elle est
contreproductive
deuxièmement à l'hystérie zh le débat et
troisièmement le ccf dans 90% des cas
privilégie la médiation il n'y a pas de
médiation possible quand vous avez jeté
en valorisables mois m pourquoi vous
avez si mauvaise presse mais je
l'expliqué alors pourquoi eric mais je
leur ai dit c'est une autre prise
communautariste qui essayent de
transformer des français musulmans en
musulmans français je ne peux pas être
plus précis pour simuler le verrière
direction islam au fromage en soit le
jeu très simple très mauvaise presse est
très simple pardonnez moi c'est en fait
là vous venez de résumer l'histoire vous
avez juste oublié de dire un truc c'est
que le ccf qui est saisie en fait de
quatre étaient prétendument
d'islamophobie en fait quand vous parlez
de médiation il va avoir les acteurs qui
sont donc des suspects dit d'être
islamophobe pour essayer d'arranger la
situation dans le cas précis de ces
miels pâtit j'ai entendu - marwan
mohammed lundi à la télévision
j'ai même croisé d'ailleurs parce que
j'étais quand même plateau puis il nous
a expliqué qu'en fait ils auraient
trouvé que c'était bien que les parents
se parle avec le professeur et c'est
pourquoi pour elle afin qu'il arrête de
parler des caricatures dans son cours
c'est pas nous c'est exactement ça mais
bien sûr tout c'est l'ancien patron du
cessez le feu
il n'a que faire arrêter ça il a dit non
à titre personnel j'ai des enfants je
fais confiance aux enseignants mais
j'imagine dans des caricatures quand
elles ont été présentées le signé par
des explications - à titre personnel je
suis maman de deux enfants de 7 et 8 ans
qui sont en ce1 et ce2 saurez plus
demain et leur institutrice qui se fait
égorger parce qu'elle aurait montré des
caricatures à mes enfants quand bien
même et je les dis et je le redis je ne
suis pas charlie et je pense que ces
caricatures ne produisent rien de
positif
si c'était arrivé dans la classe d'un de
mes enfants il serait rentré mardi maman
j'ai aujourd'hui la mairesse elle nous a
montré des caricatures je n'aurais eu
aucune réaction pourquoi parce que je
fais confiance à l'enseignante et que je
considère qu'elle a dû en montrant ses
caricatures avoir des explications je
fais aussi confiance à mon enfant dans
son dans son apprentissage à dire que je
ne vais pas demain munissez-vous venir
dire à la maîtresse toc toc toc
bonjour je sais ce que je fais c'est
certain les jours mais là c'est le
perdre alors cette notion et jetta la
syrie je peux juste signé parce que
vraiment pourquoi le ccf a mauvaise
presse faut aussi dire quelque chose
vous êtes le visage avenant de cette
organisation et je paierai que c'est
bien qu'on en voit sur les plateaux et
il a raison vous êtes le visage avenant
de cette organisation ne rien si c'est
tout l'avenir mais la vérité c'est que
des reçus au visage avenant et pardonnez
moi vous avez droit d'avoir des amis que
vous voulez mais oui ou non est ce que
vous êtes proche de hani ramadan le
frère de tariq ramadan qui est un
prédicateur qui est dans le top 10 n'est
plus des plus excités et qui est même
interdit de territoire en france et vous
aurez des conférences avec lui c'est une
vraie info ou c'est ça aussi c'est une
invention là c'est quand même pour ça
qu'ils passent à la france qu'ils
avaient tous des liens mais ce soit moi
j'essaie de comprendre parce que voilà
on voit que le ministre de l'intérieur
veut dissoudre notre mouvement et voilà
quand à la question de de geoffroy est
ce que vous êtes proche de 2 qu'est ce
que tu as quatre proches de trouver si
vous trouvez que ce qu'il dit un talent
qu'il faut en débattre
très clairement émis ramadan je les ai
rencontrés à deux reprises
moi jamais moi j'ai jamais fait
confiance et je vais d'ailleurs piqué
tout avait très clairement et très
sereinement
j'ai été porte parole entre 2014 et 2016
de la fédération des musulmans du sud à
nice qui organisait régulièrement des
conférences sur divers thèmes qui sont
liées à l'islam en tout cas et miramas
il est intervenu à deux reprises au sein
de cette association tour des
conférences et honnêtement ça date de
2015 2016 je me souviens plus des thèmes
en plan séquence n'était pas des thèmes
politiques parce qu'il y eu très très
axé sur sur ce que vous dérange pas donc
je n'ai pas entendu son discours ne vous
dérange pas donc non monsieur il le fait
de deux appartenir à une association qui
invite une personne est qui et qui le
fait intervenir ça ne veut pas dire que
je valide l'ensemble des sondes du
discours de chercher un peu comme
maintenant non non je suis désolé
regardez monsieur naulleau à nîmes à new
york depuis des années pendant des
années je sais pas si c'est pour le
cadre et bal avec ce monsieur zemmour
ils l'assurent mines et messieurs accord
avant il assume tout à fait c'est pas
sérieux mais ce que ça veut dire
commencent à naulleau en dos toutes les
ethnies contre toi c'était une plus
conférence contradictoire parce que
j'aimerais une hausse et une opposition
10 des ménages français survolent angers
parce que c'était un cours sur les
comptes le comportement en islam le lap
la première je suis plus la deuxième
partie